it's time that the European Union is
tested as is the case now
unity must prevail this is a crisis but
it can also become an opportunity for
Europe an opportunity that would allow
us to defend collectively our external
border
show solidarity to Greece and Bulgaria
and at the same time proceed with a
broader reform of our migration policy
which is one of the most emblematic
initiatives of the new Commission I have
already asked for an extraordinary
meeting of the justice and Home Affairs
ministers to discuss the pool of the
situation coordinate our efforts to
support Greece at the same time I have
asked for considerable reinforcement
through our Frontex
agency tomorrow the presence of the
three institutions also undermine Shahu
Michelle and of its authority will be in
the border and the Greek Turkish border
in a very tangible concrete so
solidarity at the moment where the
circumstances demand our leaders to be
where the problem is nobody can
blackmail and intimidate the European
Union thank